liebe genossinnen und genossen liebe
freunde an der aufzählung meiner
diversen ämter die manuelle eben gemacht
hat konnte man sie in jedem fall eines
sehen wie alt ich geworden bin
das ist nicht ärgerlich aber man hat das
zur kenntnis zu nehmen
ich will aber liebe genossinnen und
genossen am anfang dessen was ich sagen
möchte einfach schlagzeilen erinnern und
sie vorlesen
da ist zum beispiel die sozialdemokraten
haben keine chance
die spd das schlechteste wahlergebnis
ihrer geschichte bekommen
keine partei kann es gelingen einen so
deutlichen abstand aufzuholen
wisst ihr liebe genossen und genossen
aus welchem jahr
diese schlagzeilen stammen das waren
zitate aus dem jahr 2005
und wenn ich die zeitungen und
zeitschriften heute lese dann klingt mir
das doch sehr ähnlich
aber wie ist das denn 2005 ausgegangen
die umfragen sahen damals auch schlecht
aus cdu und csu bei 49% wir bei 26 also
23 punkte rückstand aber was war am ende
am ende erreichten die schwarzen gerade
mal 35 2 prozent wie er das war ein
bisschen zu wenig irgendwas für mich für
euch sicher auch 34 2 prozent
wir haben also und franz müntefering wir
haben das zusammen mit allen anderen
gemacht wir haben also über 20 prozent
punkte aufgeholt und das in wenigen
wochen
keine frage
keine frage es hat am ende knapp nicht
gereicht aber wir haben gekämpft und wir
haben aufgeholt und was damals den
kleber genossinnen und genossen das geht
heute auch
bald wohl es gibt auch in unseren reihen
die ein und den anderen die köpfe hängen
lassen
in ihnen stecken die ergebnisse der
letzten landtagswahlen verdammt tief in
den knochen hin sage ich nichts ist
entschieden nicht journalisten nicht
umfrage menschen entscheiden war sondern
sind immer noch die wählerinnen und
wähler und wir wissen dass sich ein
drittel der wähler und wählerinnen erst
am wahltag oder jedenfalls kurz bevor
entscheidet und genau dies liebe
genossinnen und genossen ist unsere
chance wenn wir in den nächsten wochen
alle kräfte mobilisieren um jede stimme
kämpfen dann können wir unser ziel
erreichen dann werden wir es schaffen
der spd zur stärksten partei zu machen
liebe freundinnen und freunden dafür
muss man kämpfen
aber man muss die macht die demokratisch
legitimierte macht um die es geht auch
unbedingt wollen und martin schult hat
deutlich gemacht er will kämpfen um
dieses amt weil er es will
das ist richtig so denn nur wer dieses
amt
unbedingt will wird es auch bekommen auf
dem weg in dieses amt
auf dem weg in dieses amt gab es eben
keine selbstzweifel geben nicht beim
kandidaten aber liebe freundinnen und
freunde auch nicht bei euch auch nicht
bei der deutschen sozialdemokratie
die anderen die schwarzen glauben dass
der staat ihnen gehöre das ist eine art
betriebsunfall bei den sozialdemokraten
regieren
das ist falsch liebe freundinnen und
freunde denn wir haben bewiesen dass wir
es können und war besser als die anderen
sein fall blieb
kein zweifel es war gut für unser land
dafür sozialdemokraten seit 1908 19 90
05 10 jahre regiert oder auch mit
regiert haben aber das ist die erfahrung
die wir doch alle gemacht haben es wäre
doch besser gewesen wenn wir die ganze
zeit über den kanzler gestellt hätten
in manchen bereichen wären wir denn
weiter als wird jetzt sind ich denke an
die zukunftssicherung unserer
sozialsysteme
ich denke an die verwirklichung der
bildungsgerechtigkeit denn liebe
genossinnen und genossen was ihr vorhat
was in eurem programm steht die
kostenfreiheit vom kindergarten bis zur
hochschule
das ist der richtige weg damit auch
kinder aus armen familien eine chance
haben
martin schulz ist ein leidenschaftlicher
europapolitiker auch in der
europapolitik stünden wir heute besser
da die tiefe spaltung im zuge der euro
krise geht auch auf das konto von merkel
und schäuble
wer die deutschen sozialdemokraten haben
jetzt mit dem neuen französischen
präsidenten marc von die große ja die
historische chance auf eine
wiederbelebung der deutsch französischen
freundschaft die auch in der substanz in
den letzten jahren gelitten hat und
hierfür und hierfür ist ein duo max
schulz jedenfalls die bestgeeignete
konstellation
liebe freunde
das kann doch kein zweifel sein die
europäische zusammenarbeit weit mehr
vertieft hat bisher ist gegenwärtig
notwendiger denn je
gerade dann wenn wir auf die vereinigten
staaten von amerika schauen und vor
allem das was gegenwärtig und dort
entgegen kommt was in den usa passiert
das muss man offen aber auch hart
kritisieren jubeln
übrigens nur nebenbei bemerkt wenn ich
gegenwärtig höre werde ich im moment so
alles von amerika emanzipieren will der
wunder ich mich schon selbst über
auftritte in bayerischen bierzelten
das waren doch es waren doch ich
erinnere mich immer diejenigen den
amerikanern in jedem auch in den
irakkrieg folgen wollten
händlern die die als wir mit eurer
unterstützung nein gesagt haben und als
antiamerikanischen brandmarken wollten
was wir weder waren noch jemals sein
werden
wir müssen wir müssen liebe genossinnen
und genossen einen präsidentin prammer
in den usa
selbstbewusst entgegentreten das
passiert mir noch ein bisschen zu wenig
in zwei punkten vor allen dingen
es ist unsere aufgabe ist es deutsche
aufgabe und europäische aufgabe gegen zu
halten
das eine sind die rüstungsausgaben dass
in diesem zusammenhang häufig angewandte
2% fiel ist niemals getroffen worden und
darauf müssen wir bestehen
wir dürfen uns eben nicht einseitig auf
das militär zu fixieren
denn wir wissen doch eine politik der
sicherheit umfasst nicht nur aspekte von
militär und polizei
nein es müssen auch die wurzeln der
unsicherheit bekämpft werden die
außenminister die sozialdemokratischen
außenminister willy brandt frank walter
steinmeier und jetzt auch sigmar gabriel
die wussten das und handeln auch
entsprechend dialog ist besser als
konfrontation überall in der welt wir
genossen zu nutzen
erweiterungen die wirtschaftspolitik
kein zweifel die vereinigten staaten von
amerika nutzen ihre ungeheure politische
macht und sie werden globale macht
bleiben um den wettmarkt wo nicht zu
dominieren jedenfalls die ersten zu sein
unternehmen wie volkswagen auch die
deutsche bank haben schwere fehler
gemacht keine frage
aber was die trompeten heute wollen ist
nicht fairer ausgleich sondern hier
sollen konkurrenzen auf den weltmärkten
klein gehalten werden
genau so agiert man in der
handelspolitik das können und das dürfen
wir im interesse der beschäftigten der
arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmer in
deutschland nicht so lassen
ein anderer aspekt vor einigen wochen
habe ich erneut mit hans jochen vogel
gesprochen hat mir einen rat für diesen
fahrzeug das mit gegeben er sagt
vergesst nicht die entspannungs politik
sie gehört einzig und allein der
deutschen sozialdemokratie und ihr liebe
genossinnen und genossen seit die erben
dieser branchen und schnitzel entfernung
politik darauf
frieden und stabilität auf unserem
kontinent das ist teil des kollektiven
bewusstsein unseres volkes kann und wird
es nur geben wenn wir vernünftige gute
beziehung auch zu unserem großen
nachbarn russland haben und in der
tradition der ostpolitik von willy
brandt und helmut schmidt kann hier bald
mehr als bisher erreicht haben und ich
bin sicher
martin wird sich darum bemühen
ich habe das programm liebe genossinnen
und genossen nicht bitte um
entschuldigung wie zeit meiner
politischen arbeit nicht vollständig
gelesen aber ich habe wahrgenommen dass
die spd erneut mit den zuständen diese
antrifft nicht zufrieden ist und genau
das auch wenn es einem gelegentlich in
dem ein oder anderen ein ärger macht
auch genau das macht die deutsche
sozialdemokratie aus und auch genau das
unterscheidet uns noch von den
konservativen aber unterscheidet von den
konservativen auch was wir unter
patriotismus verstehen wir verstehen
unter patriotismus das was bertolt
brecht in deiner kinder hymne so
wunderbar auf den punkt gesagt hat
gebracht hat also sagte und weil wir
dieses land verbessern lieben und
bestimmen wird und dass little markt
erscheinen sowie anderen völkern ist das
ist jene form von deutschen patriotismus
der mit unserer verfassung im einklang
ich finde bot gerechtigkeit zukunft
europa gerecht ist wir wissen das und
wir handeln danach
was menschen in der werks arbeit bringt
damit sie ihr leben in die eigenen hände
nehmen können
gerecht ist es immer wieder die
sozialversicherungen so zu gestalten
dass die menschen auch in zukunft gegen
die großen lebensrisiken abgesichert
sind und recht ist es auch dafür zu
sorgen
und im kern ist das auch die aufgabe der
deutschen gewerkschaften gerecht ist es
auch dafür zu sorgen dass die
wirtschaftliche basis stimmt
wir können nur das verteilen was vorher
beschaffen worden ist ob das auch das
führt zu einer nachhaltigen politik und
genau das unterscheidet uns als menschen
mit vernunft noch von dem was wir in der
linkspartei an dubiosen forderungen
antreffen
[Applaus]
zu hören ist das was martin schulz mit
anderen zusammen mit steuer und renten
konzept vorgelegt hat
verantwortungsbewusst und es ist ganz im
sinne des mottos dieses parteitages
wahrlich zukunftsorientiert jetzt muss
ich eines gleich hinzufügen
andrea ich muss dir sagen mit dem
rentenkonzept seite auf dem richtigen
dampfer
aber ich hatte nicht immer erwartet dass
wir so doll machen würde
[Applaus]
liebe freunde vom all das umzusetzen was
sie aufgeschrieben hat und heute sicher
einstimmig beschließen werde
um das zu können brauchen wir politische
macht genau deshalb wollen wir regieren
um diese sachen deutlich und
wirklichkeit werden zu lassen und
deswegen wollen wir ein bundeskanzler
martin schulz dafür muss er
wer alle noch kämpfen sind auf 13 wochen
franz müntefering wirst du das jetzt bis
auf tage und minutengenau ich bin
rechnen nicht so gut es sind noch 13
wochen bis zur bundestagswahl ist eine
lange zeit
um die stimmung zu drehen und stimmen
für die sozialdemokraten zu bekommen
aber um das zu schaffen und das
hinzubekommen wurden alle die ärmel
aufkrempeln muss sich jede und jeder
beteiligen
disziplin keine frage braucht
geschlossenheit
aber es braucht noch selbstbewusstsein
und vor allen dingen kampfeswillen geht
genau um das was auf unserer tradition
fahne von 1863 steht
einigkeit macht stark liebe genossinnen
und genossen
ich sage auch hier weil alles andere
wäre auch nicht vernünftig sage auch
hier
ich weiß dass ich es in meiner amtszeit
als bundeskanzler parteivorsitzender
nicht immer leicht gemacht habe aber
naja die gefühle jetzt leise hinzu ganz
leise hinzu ihr mir aber auch nicht
meine eines weiß ich auch in jedem der
wahlkämpfe die wir miteinander geführt
haben an deren spitze stand konnte mich
immer auf meine spd verlassen
martin schulz hat einen anspruch darauf
dass ihr ihn genauso leidenschaftlich
unterstützt er hat es verdient liebe
genossen und genoss
[Applaus]
lieber martin weber martin du hast die
leidenschaft die an politiker braucht
und in seinen ämtern hast du gezeigt
dass die verantwortung übernehmen wird
und kannst und du hast gerade in den
letzten verdammt schwierigen wochen
gezeigt dass du auch mit schwierigen und
schweren situationen fertig wirst und
was man diese man braucht das du druck
aushalten kann das eine fähigkeit in der
tat im kanzleramt noch mehr brauchen
wird als jetzt
was also alles was man für dieses amt
braucht und hat eine kampferprobte
partei hinter dir
die für die da sein wird liebe
genossinnen und genossen
liebe genossinnen und genossen ein
großer kanzler der deutschen
sozialdemokratie helmut schmidt hat beim
wahlparteitag 1998 in leipzig folgende
worte an mich gerichtet seinerzeit ich
dir martin sehr gerne mit auf den weg
geben möchte ich zitiere helmut schmidt
er sagte damals ich wünsche dir du
möglichst kein bundeskanzler werden der
zugleich mit weitblick und mit augenmaß
die richtigen der politik bestimmt ich
wünsche dir die tapferkeit das notwendig
auch dann zu tun wenn es zunächst
unpopulär ist
in diesem sinne liebe genossinnen und
genossen
auf in den kampf wenn die remos
[Applaus]